hello I'm John Mulaney oh hello I'm Nick
Kroll and we're doing a wired
autocomplete what is it see house yeah I
knew I just want you to autocomplete the
answer there's autofill autofill is when
Phil oh when we would automatically feet
feed Phil yeah who's gonna feed Phil
who's gonna feed Phil guys
Netflix across programming first one is
Nick Kroll single Nick Kroll is
singularly focused on doing a great job
in this viral video
are you single I am alone is Nick Kroll
is Nick Kroll rich not only am i
independently rich from all the money
I've made doing comedy but I come from a
wealthy family the next step is Nick
Kroll German well it's possible a number
of generations ago I was German but I
think it's fair to say that I'm no
longer German is Nick Kroll Canadian I
am NOT Canadian but I love to say the
word pasta here you go John Mulaney all
right did John Mulaney killed princess
die oh no I was so long ago who knows
what happened in that dark tunnel on
that Paris evening she was England's
rose did John Mulaney win an Emmy no I
won two Emmys that's right however the
first Emmy I received was a trick Seth
Meyers and I called the song that we
wrote for Justin Timberlake's monologue
Justin Timberlake song just as a
shorthand so when the Emmy voters were
voting for it they thought that it was
dick in a box or motherlover so we
actually got their votes and we were
fine with it we took the award okay
did John Mulaney go to college I did go
to college I went to college with Nick
Kroll oh my god yes what did John
Mulaney study oh I was an English major
with a theology minor mm-hmm where did
John Mulaney get married oh I got
married in the
skill mountains of New York State yes
because John has always wanted to be a
Jew alright it's time for a little more
Nick knowledge where did Nick Kroll grow
up uh I grew up right in my own pants
right now you know I'm saying this got
am i right makes me horny as a kid what
did Nick Kroll's parents do isn't that's
exactly how you want to be remembered
now you all of your personal
accomplishments to still be diminished
to what your parents did and do well now
you know how blanket Jackson feels to
party uh Nick
where did Nick coral go to college I
went to Georgetown University ah with a
very smart funny young man named Mike
Birbiglia did Nick Kroll audition for
SNL yes I auditioned the same year that
John Mulaney oddish August 7th 2008 with
also the same year as Jordan Peele yes
also Ellie Kemper also Eddie Murphy
departs how did Nick Kroll become how
did Nick Kroll became famous I was
dating this Nick Kroll became I was I
was dating this woman Lorena Bobbitt I'm
taking a nap she walks in with a knife
next thing you know it's a cooler
meanwhile I was the Cutco salesman that
gave her the darn thing so now I'm
feeling terrible about it
bottom line is get sewn back on I call
up my Franken dick can't believe that
works ok next peel where did Nick Kroll
zip come from where did Nick crawls zip
come from nope there's no right way to
say that what does that mean well answer
it however you think it means my zip I
think came from being a little guy you
know what I mean so you got to develop a
little bit of a zip I was a point guard
on basketball team just went back to my
elementary school the other day so that
there was padding on the walls and it is
because many years ago I ran to block a
layup and ran headfirst into a wall and
they put up padding after that
concussion yeah here we go where
was john mulaney born chicago boring
question what year was John Mulaney born
1982 boring question but can I ask you a
question
absolutely what year were you born you
know what's interesting
was John Mulaney in a frat no there were
no frats at Georgetown University and I
don't see myself joining one if there
were I don't think you would have been
good in a frat absolutely yeah any group
of men together I always thought was
hilarious
yeah and men who look up to their
fathers too much or ridiculous I'm just
so proud of my dad if you're an adult
male who sees no flaws and his father
you're an insane person yeah why was
John Mulaney on SNL why was I on us and
now why were you on us exactly well one
defense would be that I wasn't but since
you know you're turning to screws I was
asked to be on update I was never on the
show really I left and then they asked
me to host the show I'd say for me
top three SNL hosts of all time yep
Nancy Kerrigan okay
it's just Nancy Kerrigan I think she's
all your top three yeah okay you know
what no just Nancy care